this is my favorite news story all week
maybe all month
you know there's a debate raging at the
daily wire
this debate
is over the existence of aliens on the
one side on the incorrect side you have
Matt Walsh
you have Matt Walsh and all the lips
who believe in E.T
Little Green Men
it's very it's very hard for me to see
my friend Matt who is generally a wise
person
he is his head is basically screwed on
straight and he's just he's so wrong
about this then on the other correct
side of the Babe you have me
and all of the conservatives and the the
people with proper judgment who
recognize that demons are tote I'm sorry
that aliens are totally fake that was a
that was a slit because what people say
are aliens are almost certainly demons
though that's a secondary aspect of the
debate which we can get to later
this this news story today that's so
important for this National conversation
we're having
comes from Elon Musk
who happens to agree
with me a lot of people ask me you know
um
where are the aliens and I I think if if
anyone would know about aliens on Earth
it would probably be me I would think
yeah I'm like you know very familiar
with space stuff
um
and I've seen no evidence of aliens I'm
not saying that we are unique I'm simply
stating to the best of my knowledge that
there is no evidence for other uh
conscious life I I I I hope that there
is and I hope they're peaceful uh
obviously the two important
characteristics um but um we're just
saying we haven't seen anything yet so
there's no evidence
no I love this because Elon is right if
anybody on Earth
would know about aliens it would be this
guy
my only hesitation actually
at celebrating that he's on my side of
the alien debate is that
Elon Musk is so impressive and eccentric
some have suggested he might be an alien
himself
and if he were an alien then denying the
existence of aliens is exactly the sort
of thing you would expect an alien to
say so that's my only little caveat here
but generally speaking I think that Elon
Musk is a human being I think he's very
very intelligent I think he has a unique
expertise on outer space
I'm glad that he agrees with yours truly
on the matter of aliens the thing that
gets me about the alien people
is that and by I'm not talking about a
hybrid of humans and E.T I'm talking
about the people who really believe in
aliens they always go back to this
ridiculous argument they say well the
universe is so big it's just probable
that there are other life forms out
there it's so big it's just
statistically probable that
that isn't true
that represents a fundamental
misunderstanding of probability and
statistics
because in order to know the probability
the statistical likelihood of something
we have to know something about the
thing that we're talking about we have
to know something about the thing whose
likelihood we're trying to predict and
when it comes to the origin of life
we don't
I mean we do in the sense that God
created Adam and then out of his rib he
created Eve I think that's probably the
most accurate description of how life
begins that we can find and I'm sure
some dork scientist in a lab coat is
gonna say well actually it was seven
zillion years ago there was this uh
interaction of this chemical with this
other chemical and that may or may not
have some scientific validity but it's
just not a precise and accurate way to
describe it but but furthermore we don't
have any working scientific theory of
the origin of life we just those
scientists with the lab goes have no
clue whatsoever so if you don't know
even the basic aspect of the thing for
which you're trying to determine
probability and statistical likelihood
then you've got nowhere to go
the universe could be a thousand times
larger than we estimate that it is
there is still not one shred of evidence
there's not one single reason to believe
that there is any additional life beyond
our Earth say well what do you do you
think that we're unique
yeah why not there's a lot more evidence
that we're unique than evidence that
we're not unique thank you Elon thank
you Elon for proving my point right now
go to puretalk.com enter promo code
Knowles we all know about the big
wireless companies out there they lock
you into these horrendous contracts and
if you try to get out of them early they
tack on outrageous charges that is why I
made the switch to Pure Talk Wireless
where there are no hidden fees no
contracts and no hassle if you're
talking to us customer service team has
helped so many people make the switch in
as little as 10 minutes you are even
able to keep your phone number Pure Talk
has a range of affordable plans to
choose from you can find the perfect
option for your needs unlimited talk
text plenty of data just thirty dollars
a month their 5G service is super fast
consistent does not drop calls you can
get the same coverage you're used to at
half the rate that you're currently
paying Pure Talk saves the average
family over 900 dollars per year not
only will you save money but you will
also get the satisfaction of knowing
you're supporting a great American
company the CEO and chairman of puretalk
is a US military veteran when you become
I'm a Pure Talk customer you are given
the option to support America's Warrior
partnership which is an organization
that works to prevent veteran suicide go
to puretalk.com enter promo code and all
save fifty five zero percent off your
first month puretalk.com promo code
knows Pure Talk is simply smarter
Wireless speaking of aliens
will turn away from the aliens on Mars
for a second and turn toward the aliens
in Guadalajara president Trump has just
announced that he will use the military
to crush
the Mexican drug cartels
fentanyl heroin meth and other lethal
drugs are pouring across our wide open
border stealing hundreds of thousands of
beautiful American lives and it's
happening like never before in our
history children are being left without
parents families are being ripped apart
communities are being decimated
our neighbors and fellow citizens are
having their entire worlds destroyed
destroyed like nobody thought possible
our country is being poisoned from
within by the drugs and by all of the
other crime that's taking place
the drug cartels are Waging War in
America
and it's now time for America to wage
war on the cartels
in this war Joe Biden is cited against
the United States and with the cartels
they are making more money than they've
ever made before times ten
president Trump goes on he's been making
a number of these policy videos used to
be that a campaign would release a
50-page paper on here's my policy on
this or that but we live in an age that
is much more multimedia and we have we
have uh far shorter retention spans now
so I like these five-minute president
Trump policy videos what he highlights
here
is a correction to the way that
conservatives think about foreign policy
the way that foreign policy debates are
presented very often is a debate between
interventionism and isolationism
and what's curious about that
representation is that it splits the
conservatives because a lot of
conservatives think what why am I
spending 100 billion dollars potentially
sending American troops and into Ukraine
and maybe throwing us into World War
Three why would I do that and let's just
focus on our own borders but then there
are other Republicans who will say why
are we letting some two-bit strong man
push us around we're the United States
of America We Are the World Police and
we're gonna we're gonna go in maybe not
build Nations but we're going to go in
and assert our strength and our
interests so which is it what's the
conservative
answer
just looking at ourselves and being
cowardly that doesn't seem conservative
but then going around and spreading some
wilsonian project of creating
democracies everywhere and raising the
pride flag in Kandahar that doesn't seem
very conservative either the debate is
not between isolation and intervention
the debate is over what kind of
intervention are we going to have
the idea that we're going to go spend a
zillion dollars to raise a pride flag in
Kabul
is crazy especially when you consider
that we're told we're not allowed to use
our military force to stop the actual
Invasion run by some of the worst
criminal organizations on the face of
the Earth that's going on at our
Southern border right now which has a
much more direct effect on our political
order the idea that we're going to send
hundreds of billions of dollars of
weapons and potentially some of our own
young men to go fight a war in Ukraine a
territorial dispute that's been going on
for a long time when we're not going to
take care of a territorial dispute on
our own Southern border that seems crazy
to a lot of people it's just as in the
debate over Free Speech the debate over
free speech is not between free speech
on the one hand and censorship on the
other it's a debate over what standards
what taboos what Norms are we going to
have the same thing is true here foreign
policy debate is not a debate between
intervention and isolation it's where
are we going to intervene and for what
purpose hey smash that button am I a
cool hip Zoomer YouTuber yet I don't
know but you do have to subscribe you
gotta ring that Bell hit that button
because we have a lot of great content
that is coming out here on YouTube so go
check all of that out get the show every
day we'll see you later
[Music]
thank you
foreign